Everything we have done so far works
great for a few hundred megabytes. Now
let's talk about large files and we will
see why a single put request stops
working and there can be around four
separate reasons for that. Reason one is
hard limit which means that a single put
request a single upload request cannot
exceed more than 5GB and this condition
is not enforced by any specification or
your back end. It is enforced by the API
itself by the object storage itself. So
if your product accepts something like a
big videos or CAD files or database
terms or some kind of big wedding
footage, drone footage, anything these
files tend to be very large in size.
That's why if you are accepting any of
these kinds of large files, then you are
architecturally required to implement
something else instead of what we have
seen so far. Reason two is that a single
put request is either all or nothing. So
if you are uploading a file and you have
reached till 4.8 GB of the whole 5GB
file and at that moment your Wi-Fi
blinks for a while maybe the power
changed from your main connection to
your backup connection. So during that
one moment your Wi-Fi goes off and comes
again and the moment that happens your
upload is canled. There is no resume
button there and the next time you
attempt it again starts from zero and on
a real consumer connection which means
that most people who are on their mobile
data not a professional Wi-Fi which has
around 100 or 200 Mbps speed on typical
mobile networks the transfer would have
taken around 20 to 30 minute and in
between that transfer even if the
network glitch es for once their whole
operation is canceled and they have to
start again from scratch and the network
glitching for a while is very common
especially when you are on a mobile
network. Reason three is throughput and
this one goes into networking a little.
It it means that a single TCP connection
which is the connection using which we
communicate the client and server. TCP
is the one that exist behind HTTP.
Anyway, a single TCP connection it
cannot saturate a network link which
means that the throughput is is limited.
It is bounded roughly by the window size
divided by the roundtrip time and on top
of that it is extremely sensitive to any
kind of packet loss. If you lose one
packet, the whole congestion window
collapses and it has to climb back up
again. And because of that, you might
have a 200 mgabit connection, any of the
500 connection that we have these days,
but still your single stream upload it
stays at 30 mgabits. And this is the
reason why. And the fix for that is at
the network level, which is just more
number of connections. So multiple
parallel streams they each will get
their own congestion window and even if
one of them starts stalling it it will
not affect the others. And this is
exactly why if you have used download
managers like internet download manager
or free download manager these download
managers the reason they are able to
push the download speed is not because
they affect anything physically. They do
not really affect your network speed.
What they do is they open eight
different connections for the same thing
and they start downloading in parallel.
Then the reason four is user experience.
If you have a single put request, the
progress that you'll get is is very
rough. It is not very precise and on top
of that there is no ability to pause.
There is no ability to survive an
upload. If for some reason uh some kind
of network connection error happens or
the tab closes or something like that
because of all these reasons we have
this technique called a multi-art upload
and the whole protocol is only three
calls. Step one it is create multiart
upload. Here what happens you tell the
service your object provider service the
bucket the key the content type and in
return it gives you back an upload ID
and what is that upload ID? It is
basically a staging area. If you have
used git you will know what staging
means which is it is not yet committed
and you have some dirty changes in the
area and if you want you can get rid of
them. So a staging area which is the
phase before you finally make a commit.
You can imagine it like that. So this is
the area where all these parts that we
are going to see they will accumulate.
They will get stored. But at this point
nothing exists right? Nothing exists at
your key. Which means that if someone
does a get call, if someone tries to
fetch that particular key, that
particular object, they are going to get
a 404 not found error because it is
still in the staging area. The object
has not been created yet until the very
end where we will commit. Now step two
which is upload part which is once per
chunk you send the upload ID a part
number and the bytes and the important
property here is all of these are
completely independent HTTP requests and
because of that they can go in parallel
and they can go in any order which means
part seven if you have seven parts it
can arrive before part two arrives there
is no constraint there is no limitation
about the ordering of the chunks and
because of that each one if it fails for
some reason it can be retried
individually without affecting any other
chunks any other requests. Okay. And
each successful part once it reaches the
service that comes back with a E tag. We
have already discussed one property of E
tag while we are discussing about
conditional rate. Then this is the next
property the next use of E tag which is
during multipart uploads. So after each
successful attempt you will get an E tag
back and you have to keep those. Why?
Because you will need them at the end.
Now let's go to step three which is
complete multiart upload where you send
the upload ID plus the complete list of
the part numbers and their e tags in one
order. And once you send that the
service it combines all of them into one
object. And the the magical the
surprising part here is it does not
matter how many chunks there are how
large the final object is. So even if
for a 50GB object this whole call this
the final completion call it is still
the same time which means it is very
fast. It does not depend on the size of
the object. It does not depend on the
how many chunks that you're trying to
combine because the service our object
storage provider it is not really
physically combining all the 50 GB of
data. Why? Which we have already
discussed because it is a metadata
operation. What it does it records that
this object it consists of all these
parts in this order. So it it it records
the structure of that object instead of
actually combining the data in forming
one object and that is why it is
extremely fast. This is one of the
distinction that we made earlier which
is the different jobs of the metadata
plane and the data plane. Okay. Now
let's talk about the last tool which is
there is a hard limit. There is a hard
cap of 10,000 parts, 10,000 different
chunks that you can upload with
multipart, which means that the the size
of the chunk that you're choosing for
each part, the size of each part, it
depends a lot on what you're trying to
achieve. So, if you just go ahead with a
default size, something like 5 mgabytes
per part. So, 5 mgabytes*
10,000 is 50 GB, which means that that
is the largest file you can upload. You
cannot upload beyond that because each
file each chunk has already taken five
MB decided by you and there is a hard
cap of 10,000. So by mistake if you
choose 5 MB and you start uploading a 60
GB file using multipart upload then your
upload will fail exactly at the part
10,000. after 10,000 it allow you
exactly at the part 10,01 it'll fail
after 50 GB has been transferred which
is a very expensive operation that is
why the correct approach here is to
compute the part size keep the part size
dynamic depending on the file size
instead of keeping a default size. So
take the whole file size and divide it
by the 10,000 and whatever number you
get that is the number of parts that you
need to send to complete this object.
But dynamic is something that we should
not always do because if it is a small
file then it does not make sense for us
to make it 10,000. So there should be
another dynamic formula somewhere which
decides let's say we have a default size
of 16 or 32 MB and we have an object
which is of a few GBs and we do this
whole calculation of divided by 10,000
and etc and the final part number that
we decide it should be whichever is
larger either your default number that
you have already decided based on your
typical usage of your app or the part
number whichever is largest you can take
it that gives you a very good balance of
uh choosing the part number. I
personally use around 16 or 32 mgabyte
as a floor which means that it can
handle files up to a 160 or 320 GB
without thinking a lot about the formula
and all. So why not just use huge parts
like big parts? The reason is because
the part is going to be your retry
granularity which means that if a single
part fails you have to of course retry
the whole part you have to resend the
whole thing with a new request. So if
you are on a mobile connection and the
part size is 500 MB 500 mgabyte and that
part that particular part fails then you
have to again retry with 500 MB of data
as compared to if these are small parts
which means that uh if it is around 16
to 32 MB then retries become very cheap
you don't have to worry a lot about
retry being expensive. So 16 to
somewhere around 64 as max is the
perfect sweet spot which takes care of
pretty much everything. Okay. Now let's
talk about a famous bug which is related
to E tag. For a normal single put
request the E tag of that object is
going to be MD5 hash of its contents.
MD5 is a famous hashing algorithm
hashing function which gets used for
this. So a lot of people they very
reasonably write these integrity checks
which say that hash the file locally and
after they receive the e tag they
compare it and if both the hashes match
then the file upload was clean. This
works well when you are doing the normal
upload but the moment you start using
the multiart uploads the e tag that you
receive it is not the MD5 hash of the
thing that you just uploaded. What in in
case of multiart uploads it is the hash
the MD5 hash of each binaries MD5 hash
and then a hyphen and then the number of
parts. So if you check the e tag of a
multiart upload you'll see something
like -42 in the end. So if you need uh
real end to-end integrity, you should
not use e tax. There is a separate
feature called the check sum feature.
The modern SDKs if you're using AWS S3,
the modern AWS S3 SDK, they will compute
a CRC 32C or a 256 per part and they
will let you request a full object check
sum and the service will verify it for
you. Or what you can do is which I
usually do which is compute your own SHA
256 hash of the file on the client send
it as user metadata and verify it in a
background job after upload. If you do
that that will also give you uh
dduplication for free. Okay. Now let's
talk about the fourth call which is abot
multiart upload. Let's look at what
happens when a multi-art upload fails
halfway. Let's say you have uploaded 300
parts and each is around 32 MB. So
that's roughly 10 GB of data sitting in
the staging area. Then the user closes
the tab and completion the complete
multiart API that has never called and a
bot was never called. What happens then?
those 10 GB of data they are still
stored and you will be still build for
them every month forever even though you
cannot see them why because they don't
really show up when you do the bucket
listing when you call the list API in
the bucket why because the object itself
the list tries to find the objects and
since these are multipart uploads the
object does not exist yet so this is a
bucket I set up for this video and And
if you look at the console, it shows one
object in it. A 184 mgabytes object. So
as per us, as per what we see in the
console, this is the object. This is the
size of the data that we are being built
for right by AWS. Now if we ask the API
using our AWS CLI, what do we ask? The
command is to list all the multiart
uploads that are started but never
finished. That's what this command does.
And as you can see, there are three of
them which are initiated days ago. And
some of the parts that were already
pushed, they are still sitting there
totaling around 460 MB. And none of
these appear anywhere in any kind of
listing API. and they also don't appear
in the console as we just saw but you
are still paying for it. So what is the
solution for this? It is to add a life
cycle rule which says abort or cancel
any incomplete multiart uploads after 7
days instead of accumulating all those
for days and weeks and months. And that
is a configuration you should have for
every single bucket that you configure
in your production before you start uh
writing any feature before you start
writing any code. 7 days is a very good
balance a very good default. It it does
not really cost you anything and it
permanently uh closes a leak. So very
important thing to keep in mind once you
start uh using multipart uploads. Now
that we have learned about both and
multipart, now it's time to combine them
because that is what we use in
production for uploading large files
from web from our browsers. So this is
what the full architecture would look
like. First, your browser makes an API
call to your back end which is something
like post/uploads/init
and it sends the file name, the size of
the file and the type of the file. Then
what your back end does, it uh checks
whatever authentication and
authorization it has to do. It will
compute what is the ideal part size that
we just talked about which is either the
default or the dynamic part size
whichever is the largest. Then it will
call create multiart upload and it will
insert a row in our database with a
status called as pending which we
already talked about in the first video
and then it will presend the URL for
each part and as a response to the
browser it sends the upload ID the part
size for each part and all the URLs for
each part. Then it's time for the
browser to communicate with the bucket.
So the browser starts n parallel
requests whatever the ideal concurrent
connection uploads that you think is the
right around four to six maybe. So n
means four to six parallel put requests
from the browser to the bucket. After
those are done, then the browser calls
an API to our back end again, something
like post/upload/complete.
And here it attaches the upload ID and
an array of all the parts. For each
part, it will send the part number and
the E tag for that. on the back end side
our API it will then try to connect to
our bucket our S3 and it will call the
complete multiart upload request after
that is done as you have discussed in
the first video it will do a head call
head object call for a verification
whether the content type the size and
the number all of them match or not for
the object that was claimed by the
browser after that is done it will turn
the particular DB V row from status
pending to status completed or status
ready whatever and on top of that if you
have a Q- based architecture for
different needs the back end will emit
an event something like file.uploaded
uploaded event into the queue so that
the queue can if it wants it it can do
some kind of audit logging or it will
send the event back through websocket to
front end to show so some kind of UI
confirmation. That's pretty much the
whole architecture of multiart upload
combined with pre-signed URLs. A few
notes on this whole architecture is do
not pre-sign 10,000 URLs up front if
that is the number of parts you require
or the browser requires for the size of
the file. Instead, what you can do, you
can pre-sign in batches of maybe a 100
as the browser works through them as it
finishes the uploads. Otherwise your
response for the init API call by the
browser it will become a few megabytes
of JSON. Second note the concurrency
that we talked about for the parallel
put requests from the browser to the
bucket four to six parallel requests put
requests are the good balance a perfect
sweet spot. If you try to push beyond
that then you might encounter issues uh
where you are fighting for the same
bandwidth between different devices of
the network or different processes.
Third, the browser can read a slice of a
file without loading the whole thing.
Why? Because if you have worked with any
of the front-end libraries, a file
object, that's how we in JavaScript
interact with files in browsers. It
gives you a slice method. If you call
that, it returns you a blob. And that
blob that we call it is lazy. Which
means it is not loaded up front. It is
only loaded into memory when it is
required. So the memory usage is related
to the part size not the complete object
size. So it will be around the part size
times the concurrency not the complete
file size. Fourth and this is about the
course thing that I mentioned at the end
of the last video. You have to expose
the E tag response header in the buckets
in your S3 buckets course config
otherwise your browser your JavaScript
cannot read the E tag of the response
that the bucket sends back and you
cannot complete the upload. And after we
do all of these the capability to resume
a big upload we get that automatically.
So if the page is refreshed the client
our browser it asks our API this
question which is but do I have an
upload in progress for this particular
file and then our back end looks up in
our database and finds that pending row
and it calls the list parts function
call again with the upload ID to find
out exactly which parts the bucket
already has in the staging area. And
then it returns a fresh set of
pre-signed URLs only for the missing
ones, the ones that got cancelled or
that got failed because of the browser
refreshing or the browser tab closing.
So the client takes those parts and it
resumes from that point instead of
starting from zero. So somewhere from
part 341 or something like that. Okay.
So this is the same upload page but the
file this time that we are trying to
upload is of 2GB. So let's look at what
the server does with it. Unlike before,
it does not sign one URL. It starts a
multi-art upload and the plan the whole
strategy it comes back with is the part
size is going to be uh 16 MB each and
the total number of parts are going to
be a 125 and at a time decided by the
browser at a time five of them are going
to go to the bucket. So the concurrency
limit that we talked about for
parallelly uploading the parts from the
browser to the bucket in this case it is
five here. So as you can see from this
grid every square in this grid is one
part. Total we have around uh 125 parts.
The gray means those parts are waiting
to be uploaded. The blue ones that you
see blinking those are inflight requests
which means they are currently being
uploaded and at a time you can see that
five of them are blinking in blue which
means five of them are being uploaded in
parallel. The green means those are
already uploaded. So this whole process
of the grid filling in with the inflight
request with the completed with the
waiting all of these can be combined
together to form a formula to show this
progress bar in which instead of
glitching it shows a continuous
progress. And if you see the network
panel you'll see around 125 separate put
requests for each part. And all of them
are going straight into the bucket's own
domain. They are not going to our back
end. And the rate and the estimate which
we are showing here for the progress
they are computed. They are not given to
us by the server. They are computed from
the parts that are already finished and
the parts that are waiting to get
uploaded. And [clears throat] because of
that those since those are stable
numbers that is why they the progress
part does not jump around. And finally
when the last part lands once the last
part is finished the browser sends one
more request which is the complete
request to our API not to S3 to our API
with the list of parts and their e tags.
Okay now that the file is in the bucket
and a user wants it back. So far we have
been talking about uploads different
kinds of upload different patterns of
upload multipar resuming cancelling all
this stuff. Now it's time to talk about
downloads because downloads are the
cases where people spend most of their
data. The number of times browsers or
apps fetch files is far greater than the
number of times they upload. Right? So
now let's understand the download side
of our buckets. The first rule and this
is something we talked about uploads
also but it again repeats here but this
time it is more important which is do
not relay or do not proxy your downloads
through your application through your
back end. Why? Because if your handler,
you have your handler, it does a get
object call to our object storage and
then it copies the bytes whatever it
gets to the response one by one. Then as
we uh discussed earlier every download
it involves it consumes it keeps busy
one of your servers workers either your
go routine either your event loop or
something like that for the entire
download duration and typically in our
production we pay for bandwidth we don't
just pay for our CPU cycles or memory we
also pay for how much data is being
traveled felt through your network. If
your infrastructure is somewhere like
AWS or pretty much every single
infrastructure whatever that you're
using platform as a service or any cloud
provider they charge for bandwidth. On
top of all these disadvantages the
downloads itself are slow. Why? because
compared to the the right solution which
is CDN with caching that we'll talk
about soon which has zero bandwidth cost
because the data does not travel through
your server but it also offers very fast
downloads why because CDN servers are
usually spread across the whole world in
every region in every country as
compared to a server which is maybe in a
particular region or two three different
regions. So ideally whatever data is
going out of your bucket whenever users
request the file they should go directly
from the bucket or the CDN if you have
configured that for latency reasons then
directly from CDN. It should never go
from your server as a relay. So for this
we have around three different patterns.
The number one pattern it is pretty
simple. If the content that is being
requested it is like objectively public
things like your websites, your apps
images, your CSS bundle or the product
images which are supposed to be public,
which are accessible to anyone and you
don't care about the security or
privacy, then make the bucket public or
even better put a CDN in front of it and
make the bucket private. put a CDN in
front of it and only let the CDN read
the bucket and on top of that you can
set a very long cache control and use a
content addressed key which means that
the the key is the hash of your contents
whatever file it is that's what we mean
by content address and it is a very
popular term whenever we are talking
about CDNs so make the keys content
addressed and if you do that your whole
URL for those objects will change
whenever the content changes and you
don't have to worry about anything. Very
straightforward pattern and it is used
very widely. This is going to be the
cheapest and the fastest option that is
available to you. Then comes pattern two
which is pre-signed get which is pretty
much similar to what we saw with
pre-signed put where presigned put but
here instead of pre-signing a put
request you will resign a get request.
So the whole workflow of browser being
able to communicate with S3 it is going
to be the same for presign get also your
browser will send a request to your
server. Your server your back end will
authorize the request by checking
whether the user has access to this
particular object that they are
requesting or not. And if they are
allowed to access this, you will give
them back as a response a URL a
pre-signed get that is only valid for
around let's say 5 to 15 minutes
whatever works for your app. Now there
is a problem here with pre-signed get
that we need to pay attention to which
is a pre-signed URL. It contains a
timestamp and a signature. So every time
a user requests the same file they get a
different URL which means that from a
CDN's point of view the content delivery
network every request that you are
making from a CPOV it is a different
resource it is for a different object
and because of that your cache hit rate
the number of times you are able to get
that data back from the cache is going
to be zero. So now you have put a CDN in
front of your bucket exclusively for
caching but it is not able to cache. It
is not really doing anything and you are
still paying for the full bandwidth the
egress. Egress is the term that we use
in infrastructures whenever we are
talking about data going out. So for
this issue there are two different
fixes. The cheap one is to change the
expiry. So instead of signing with
something like this is valid for next 15
minutes from now, you will sign like
this. This is valid until the top or the
next hour. So every user who requests
that file within the same hour, it will
get the same URL and the CDN is able to
cache it. But you will lose a bit of a
precision on the expiry time by gaining
a little cash it ratio. But if you want
to do the proper fix the right way
because uh you have already reached your
scale then you can use uh you should use
the CDN itself has its own signed URLs
or signed cookies. So the authorization
thing that happens which your back end
is doing that happens at the edge. Edge
basically means that um the the compute
the the small servers that are spread
across the whole world that sit at every
network node. So the whole authorization
process happens at the edge of the
network and the city itself has full
control over the caching instead of the
back end being involved. these uh signed
cookies that I mentioned, these are very
convenient especially for video because
they're a single session of video. It
pulls hundreds and thousands of segments
of files because the video is being
streamed and because of that if it goes
through your server your back end you
would have had to sign hundreds and
thousands of URLs while the video was
being streamed. So in this case letting
the CDN handle that workload is much
more convenient and the right way to do
it. Okay. Now let's come to an important
part of downloading or fetching which is
range requests. It's very important
especially with some of the development
in our modern web. The idea is very
simple here. The idea is very simple
here. It lets the client the browser say
that don't send me the whole thing. send
me the bytes starting from 1 million up
to 3 million or 2 million. And the
server it responds with status 206 which
means partial content as per the HTTP
semantics and it also sends a content
range header which says which bytes
exactly these are and how big the whole
thing is going to be. But if the range
that the client send, the browser send
is invalid or is nonsensical, you'll get
the status 416 which is range not
satisfiable. This whole thing that I
just talked about the client sending the
range request, the server communicating
the support back with HTTP headers. This
is a HTTP semantic. This is not invented
by object storage itself. And since in
the and if you remember in the first
video we talked about where we said that
one of the reasons object storage is so
convenient, it is so powerful is because
everything happens through HTTP requests
and HTTP is one of the most common
protocols which is implemented by pretty
much every single computing device that
you can imagine. And now because of this
whole uh range read thing which is
supported by HTTP, it is also supported
by native object storage itself for
sending partial objects or ranged
objects. And now if you combine those
two ideas, HTTP providing the capability
for clients to fetch parts of a resource
and S3 our object storage supporting the
same protocol to send parts of an
object. If you combine those, there are
a lot of ideas that gets unlocked from
that powerful combination. For example,
you have a video and you take the
scrubber on a video and you drag it to
the 30 minute mark. It was on zero and
you drag it to 30 minute. The moment you
do that, the browser does not have to
download the first 30 minutes. What it
does? It looks at the files index, the
whole files index and it calculates
roughly which bite offset is
corresponding to the 30 minutes mark.
And once it figures that out which is
like a like microcond call or
milliseconds call it starts a range
request starting from that bite and it
ignores the first part the first 30
minute part and then the request reaches
CDN and CDN sends the bite starting from
there and it instantly starts playing
from that point instead of having to
worry about the part that got skipped.
Using the same mechanism is how
resumable downloads work. For example,
as we talked about download managers.
Let's say your download manager they got
to the bite 400 million and at that
point the connection dropped the Wi-Fi
stopped working or something happened.
The moment it comes back up, the
connection comes back up and they have
internally some kind of retry mechanism.
Then what they do? they re-request from
bite 400 million the exact point where
it stopped because of the network error
and they do that with a range header
which we already mentioned. So now when
we come back to the idea of parallel
downloads that I mentioned which
download managers do to boost the
download speed without affecting the
physical connection itself. This idea
sits on top of that and complements that
which is open six different connections
for the same object and in each
connection you handle different ranges.
Okay, let's see a demo for this one the
range requests here in the terminal if
you see the command what I'm asking is I
am asking for the first 100 bytes of the
object. Now this is communicating with
my local instance which is a docker
hosted menu object storage instance but
that is not the thing to focus here. The
thing to focus here is the interaction
between the client and the object
storage. So if you look at the status
the status is 206 which as I said means
partial content. Now to also look at
something more useful. If we ask for the
first eight bytes and we pipe whatever
the response that we get to a hex dump
using a tool called XXT, what we get is
a PNG header. And now because of the
whole interaction, because of the range
requests and us being able to read a
part of the file, we know that this file
is a PNG file without downloading the
whole PNG, without downloading the whole
image. Now here it looks very basic but
when we are trying to optimize the
performance of our clients and servers
having tricks like that in our arsenal
is going to help us a lot by minimizing
the latency and also reducing waste any
kind of bandwidth or processing. And
lastly we can also start downloading a
large file and if you want we can kill
it in between and then we can start
resuming it again. The curl command if
you see it asks for the range that is
missing and depending on that the object
store in this case the menu instance it
serves it only those ranges and the
download keeps continuing instead of
starting from scratch. These progressive
download over ranges they work very good
up to a particular point. But there is
one limitation here which we cannot
really fix and that is there is exactly
one version of the file. And what that
means is especially if you look at how
different kinds of video rendering
architectures work all these streaming
sites like Netflix, YouTube, Amazon
video, Hot Star, whatever streaming
sites, video streaming sites that you
notice, they of course have a very
complex architecture. But the core idea
behind all of them is you don't serve
the same file to every user. So all
these different companies, all these
different platforms, they have this
architecture where they are able to
detect how good the user's connection is
and based on that they either serve a
small lowquality file or they serve a 4K
very high quality file and that whole
thing happens with a technique called as
segmented streaming using formats like
HLS or DASH.
So there what you do you transcode.
Transcode basically means converting the
internal formats of the video for our
own purpose for different different use
cases. So you transcode the whole
original file into different kinds of
qualities. After that you chop you cut
down each one into different segments of
a few few seconds and in the end you
write a manifest file which records
whatever that you did and all the
mappings for those files basically the
listing. Now in the client side when the
player the video player whatever that
you're using it fetches the manifest
first and then it starts fetching the
segments one at a time and between these
segments between fetching these segments
it measures its own download speed how
long it is taking to get all these
segments and depending on that it
decides whether to fetch a higher
quality segment or to drop down to a
quality depending on how long the last
segment took to fetch. That's what we
call as adaptive bit rate. You might
have heard this phrase a lot when we are
talking about videos and audios and
streaming and all this stuff. But the
the interesting part, the useful part
here is nothing really changes from your
object storage side. You are still
storing the same file. The segments
themselves are objects and the manifest
file that we just talked about which
lists all those segments and maps them
that itself is an object. So the object
storage plus a CDN if you combine both
of them you have pretty much everything
you need for building your own video
streaming platform. But of course the
the hard engineering part here is the
whole transcoding pipeline and the
background job that gets triggered every
time someone does an upload to start
this whole transcoding pipeline. The
whole cues and workers and all of these
things. So that is where the core
engineering lies not the serving part.
The serving part is already solved by
major object storage providers and CDNs.
So if this video streaming this video
serving is is a just a small feature of
your product then you should go for a
hosted video service something like Mox
or Bunny Cydian those two are the ones I
have used and you let them do all the
transcoding or whatever that we
discussed the the hard engineering parts
but if you are building a streaming
platform yourself the video streaming is
the 90% of the platform then you have to
build the whole pipeline yourself to
make the cost make sense. Now let's talk
about money because the pricing model of
what you're using which service that
you're using it affects your
architecture a lot. So all in all there
are three different things that you are
built for that you pay for. First is the
storage which is measured as per
gigabyte per month. That is the number
one. Then comes operations which is per
request. How many requests that you are
making to the object storage. And in
requests also the writes the the put
requests or any kind of mutations that
you are doing deletes or whatever they
are roughly 10 times more expensive as
compared to reads which is just getting
the object doing a get call to fetch the
object. And the last one is egress.
Egress is the term you'll hear a lot in
cloud architecture. Egress basically
means all the data that is going out of
your cloud provider. So whenever users
or you request files from the object
storage that is going to be counted
under egress because the file went out
of the object storage of the cloud
provider and that is one of the reasons
services like Cloudflare Cloudflare R2
which is another very famous object
storage provider. It is very famous
because it provides free egress which
means it does not charge you a single
rupee or a single scent. Does not matter
how much data that you fetch from your
object storage which is a huge deal if
if your app requires that kind of volume
and the whole cost thing keeps changing
every few years. So that is not
something I want to cover in a
architecture video. So you should refer
to the pricing page and all the stuff.
Okay, I think that's pretty much all I
wanted to cover about object storage. So
let's do a recap since it's been a
pretty large video in two parts. Object
storage exists because our local file
system, local file storage does not
really scale. And object storage scales
by giving up this very important
property which is called mutability
which means no editing in place, no
rename, no folders, no locks and in
exchange for effectively infinite
capacity and what AWS calls as 11 9 of
durability and a complete HTTP
interface. All of these are provided in
exchange. Then an object is a key, some
bytes
and some metadata in a completely flat
name space which is your bucket. Folders
in object storage are just a group by
operation on a string. Always generate
the key yourself. Put high entropy
strings in the front. try to encode, try
to store ownership information inside
them and set your metadata during write
time because you can't update the med
without rewriting the whole object.
Behind the scenes there is a metadata
plane and a data plane. Durability comes
from this famous technique called as
erasure coding which is used by these
object storage providers which is a
cheaper and stronger strategy compared
to replication. Next durability does not
mean backup. Backup means versioning and
replication which you have to explicitly
do which is not provided to you by
default. Never issue, never run a list
request on top of the bucket unless you
know what you're doing. So if you are
doing list request just to see how many
files or what are the files your user
contains then that is wrong. Always keep
your database for that kind of
information. Your database should record
what are the files available, what file
this user has. In object storage, you
fetch that exact file back. You don't
look what are the things that are
available for uploads. Small files can
go through your server as long as you
stream them and you have a limit on the
body size. Large files should go
directly from the browser with something
called as pre-signed URLs. And always
use pre-signed post URL with a content
length range and never a plain
pre-signed put request because a
pre-signed put request is a unlimited
write capability and someone can abuse
that if they want. Always record the
intent of the client of your browser in
your database before the upload starts.
And once the upload finishes and your
client calls the complete API, you
verify the whole thing with a head
object call and then you run some kind
of background process to clean up
whatever things that are abandoned. For
large files, multiart upload where you
start create the parallel parts and you
complete and you do the whole browser
server and S3 operation. Always compute
your part size from the file size
dynamically instead of always using the
default. Don't trust the E tags on
multiart objects and always use the abot
incomplete multiart life cycle rule on
every bucket that you ever create from
day one. For downloads, never use your
server as a relay or a proxy. Always use
a pre-signed get URL and try to use CDN
with a cache with a private bucket
pattern which works very well in a lot
of cases. Range requests are how we do
different kinds of seeking operation. We
can do resuming and parallel download
and all this stuff and object storage
natively supports that. For videos, we
try to segment it and we have
specialized players to adapt based on
the segments. That's pretty much the
whole recap.